[Musica]
c'è un termine con cui faccio
francamente fatica a confrontarmi e
questo termine è un po' la sensazione
che si prova Quando si è innamorati no
si sentono le farfalle nello stomaco
magari i ragazzi più giovani che ci
vedono dal su lo hanno provato lo stanno
provando si sente il cuore che palpita e
poi si suda perché magari non si è
corrisposti dalla persona che si ama si
sente una specie di odi e t'amo
simultaneo qualcosa che ci piace ma che
ci fa anche molto arrabbiare che non
riusciamo ad afferrare Ebbene a me
capita la stessa cosa quando mi metto
quotidianamente di fronte a questa
parola e la parola è verità
Caspita una parola che fa tremare i
polsi soprattutto per chi fa
informazione soprattutto per chi ha
fatto della verità della sfida della
verità il proprio lavoro
la verità è il luogo della complessità
dentro la verità noi troviamo le
risposte a questa complessità Ma certo
bisogna afferrarla e la verità ha messo
in crisi tantissime persone nel corso
della storia pensate per esempio Ponzio
Pilato di fronte a Gesù in quel processo
incredibile e lui dice È la verità cos'è
la verità No perché chiaramente non la
sa più afferrare perché gli elementi sul
tavolo sono talmente complessi che
Pilato non sappiamo dove girarsi se ne
lava le mani
Pilato non Cerca la verità perché non la
può trovare e la verità sfida tutti noi
soprattutto in questo tempo Guardate mi
pare e non so cosa ne pensiate che
questo sia un tempo in cui abbiamo
sostituito il pensiero ha la forza
dell'immagine alla forza del video ve lo
dice uno che con le immagini Ci lavora
quando la forza dell'immagine diventa
pervasiva talmente tanto da farci vivere
in un Var perenne in uno slow motion
continuo in un reversal angolo che ci
deve far vedere tutto di un fatto E
perché solo quella Prova solo quella
prova video o fotografica fuori donarci
la realtà può ritrovarci la verità
allora compiamo un piccolo errore per
metà è vero ma manca l'altra metà Adesso
ve lo spiego cos'è l'altra metà e per
spiegarvelo voglio partire da questa
foto e forse più Age qua in questo
teatro La ricorderanno eccola qui questo
Cormorano Cormorano ehm pubblicato in
prima pagina sul Washington Post il 26
gennaio del 1991 è un cormorano con le
penne inzuppate di petrolio E allora vi
ricordate Si disse Saddam ha aperto i
Pozzi e oltre al genocidio ha creato un
enorme catastrofe ambientale e questo
Cormorano è un'immagine vera o è
un'immagine falsa
è un'immagine Vera si tratta di un
Cormorano è il contesto che è falso
un'immagine vera se il contesto è falso
può originare una notizia falsa e chi ce
l'ha spiegato che questo Cormorano era
vero ma la notizia il contesto era falso
non il giornalismo ce l'hanno spiegato
un gruppo di ornitologi francesi pensate
che hanno guardato questa immagine e
hanno detto Ma no si tratta di un baby
Cormorano e questo Baby Cormorano non
può nidificare in quel periodo lì lungo
le coste del Golfo e infatti questo è un
cormorano che risale alla guerra
iranirak del 1983 vedete quanto è
complessa la ricerca della verità e
allora io mi sono chiesto
a marzo quando per 40 giorni sono stato
a Kiev a raccontare la prima parte del
conflitto è possibile oggi un cormorano
bis cioè con tutta la tecnologia che
abbiamo con tutta questa informazione
anche visiva che abbiamo è possibile
incappare nella mancanza di contesto
perché sapete quando non c'è
contestualizzazione quando si inquinano
I Pozzi della contestualizzazione la
verità è irraggiungibile e l'ho provato
sulla mia pelle sabato 12 marzo alle 4
del pomeriggio insieme a due fotografi
entriamo dentro questa località irpin
forse ve la ricorderete questa località
con il ponte crollato da cui scappavano
i profughi per raggiungere la salvezza a
Kiev ed entriamo lì intorno alle 4 del
pomeriggio e improvvisamente nella
piazza centrale bombardata Assisto a
questa scena
Queste sono immagini che ho girato io
con il mio telefonino con il mio iPhone
è di primo acchito ho pensato Ho uno
scoop in mano ho finalmente la
possibilità di riprendere come vengono
trattati prigionieri russi perché si
tratta di Tre uomini e lo vedete Legati
con il cellophane a un palo meno 10
gradi denudati dalla vita in giù privati
di ogni dignità con una patata in bocca
perché non potessero parlare con i
giornalisti
se non avesse prevalso dentro di me
l'urgenza del contesto io avrei preso
quell'immagine così come Mi appariva
dei militari ucraini che col kalashniko
puntato
tenevano le vite di tre persone in
queste condizioni e allora ho chiesto Ho
chiesto al militare con il kalashnikov
di raccontarmi chi fossero e lui mi ha
risposto è la peggior feccia Ucraina
e allora ho capito che non mi trovavo di
fronte a dei prigionieri russi Ma
certamente di fronte dei prigionieri
ucraini E chi erano questi prigioniero
ucraini ladri sciacalli che si erano
introdotti nelle case di irpine le
avevano saccheggiate mentre le persone
scappavano e allora ho chiesto e questa
è la punizione che combinate ai ladri sì
uno di loro improvvisamente ha preso un
taglierino e ha tagliato il cellophane
ha preso queste tre persone le ha fatte
inginocchiare le ha fatte mettere con le
mani dietro la nuca e ha spianato il suo
Kalashnikov contro di loro in quel
momento io ho pensato che di fronte a
quella scena la mia emotività era ben
più mossa rispetto addirittura alle
scene che avevo visto il giorno prima
con i cadaveri di una famiglia per
strada che cercava la salvezza e che la
Pietà di qualcuno aveva coperto con un
lenzuolo e perché mi aveva mosso così
tanto questa immagine Ma perché dentro
di loro c'era ancora la vita perché
queste tre persone erano tre persone
ancora vive e allora ho chiesto al
militare gli sparerete
e lui mi ha risposto queste uniche due
parole Purtroppo no
capite quanto è complesso dentro queste
due parole Purtroppo no ballano le vite
di tre persone
ci sono domande complesse che ho
incontrato nel mio lavoro e che
richiedono risposte complesse e a cui
anche il giornalismo ha dato risposte
semplici
Come si fa a fermare per esempio la
crisi Umanitaria di persone che arrivano
verso l'Europa domanda complessa
risposta semplice blocca navale Come si
fa a dire a una donna a una ragazza che
ritorna a casa in periferia all'una di
notte e che ha paura è che questa paura
è una paura irrazionale una domanda
complessa la risposta i reati sono in
calo vedete la complessità è multiforme
e dentro la complessità dobbiamo saperci
stare e ci sono Ho tentato di starci
soprattutto quando ho raccontato qui da
Cremona
le vostre terapie Intensive era lunedì 2
marzo 2020 e la domanda complessa era è
o no poco più di un influenza il covid e
ho cercato di rispondere con la forza
delle immagini Sì ma dando anche un
contesto
è durato il tempo di un amen perché
subito dopo sono arrivate Ve lo
ricordate le bare dentro i camion
militari di Bergamo e subito dopo è
arrivato il dubbio irrazionale Guardate
contro il dubbio irrazionale che là
dentro non c'erano dei cadaveri non si
può fare assolutamente nulla la ragione
non può non riesce il giornalismo Trova
un ostacolo perché il dubbio razionale è
un Booster contro la verità e quando
subentra la dubbio razionale quando
ciascuno di noi si rinchiude dentro se
stesso si fa a riccio io lo chiamo il
rachitismo della verità
quando non siamo più in grado di
guardarla negli occhi la verità di
accettarla quando le paure Subentrano e
sono più forti
e come possiamo
sciogliere queste immagini in un
concetto di verità
perché L'errore che abbiamo fatto tutti
noi è quello di sostituire le iqos cioè
ciò che si vede la figura l'immagine no
con
leidos ovvero l'idea che noi ci facciamo
di quell'immagine
e quando arriva questa sostituzione è
finita
Allora concludendo che cosa può fare il
giornalismo Adesso vi ho fatto un po' la
diagnosi Viva il giornalismo ma a basso
il giornalismo quando il giornalismo non
è fatto tenendo conto del contesto
allora vi lascio cinque parole che per
me sono state fondamentali la prima di
queste cinque parole è la parola suola
delle scarpe torniamo a consumare la
scuola delle scarpe alziamo i nostri
culi di pietra dalle redazioni torniamo
a stare in mezzo alle persone torniamo a
stare alla stessa altezza delle loro
storie e torniamo soprattutto perché
perché altrimenti tutti quelli che noi
andiamo a raccontare la politica in
primis Che cosa fa usa i social per
comunicare direttamente le loro tribù e
si sottrae alle domande del giornalismo
e il giornalismo che fa se stai in
relazione non può fare le domande prende
quelle dichiarazioni le mette in pagina
nei propri telegiornali e le ridà al
pubblico così come sono senza un
interlocuzione senza interrogarle
tornare a consumare la suola delle
scarpe lo dico a tutti noi e chiedo
tutti voi di pretenderlo dal giornalismo
la seconda parola è relazione non è una
parola che riguarda solo giornalismo ma
Viva Dio se non entriamo in relazione
con le persone che raccontiamo se non
stiamo la stessa altezza del loro dolore
dico sempre non troppo in alto per non
essere pietistici ma nemmeno troppo in
basso per non subire noi per primi
quello stesso dolore no Ha la stessa
altezza guardandoli negli occhi cercando
di stare dentro le loro storie il mio
vecchio parroco quando avevo 16 anni mi
diceva Alessio fatti dentro fatti dentro
nella vita
mordila stai all'altezza delle storie
che racconti
Ecco recuperare la relazione recuperare
questo contesto è fondamentale e c'è
un'altra parola che mi sta molto a cuore
e è appartenenza
Voi direte Cosa c'entra col giornalismo
l'appartenenza No c'entra C'entra eccome
Sapete qual è l'etimologia di
appartenenza Io sono andato a cercarla
perché mi sono interrogato su questo e
deriva da ad
che è qualcosa che va verso qualcuno e
pertineo e se avete Pertini o cosa
significa significa
mi riguardi
se mi appartieni mi riguardi
E se ti appartengo io ti riguardo e
questo c'è nella relazione giornalistica
tra il giornalista La sua fonte tra il
giornalista e le storie che racconta e
pensate Quanto è bello questo termine
riguardarsi cioè non guardarsi un'unica
volta non è un'azione che si esaurisce
in un tempo limitato è un'azione
continua è continuare 10 100 1000 volte
a guardare ancora le cose a entrare
dentro nella sostanza e nel cuore dei
fatti che raccontiamo per cercare di
sciogliere la complessità di quei fatti
la quarta parola è semplicità Vi
sembrerà contraddittoria con il tema
della complessità invece non lo è break
diceva la semplicità è difficile a farsi
E a me piace questa idea artigianale
della semplicità la semplicità è un
bisturi immaginatevela così come un
bisturi che taglia le facce complesse di
un prisma e parcellizzando quella
complessità la spiega
l'ultima parola ve la racconto con
questa fotografia
non è questa è l'ultima fotografia ed è
questa qua Questo è
Geppetto di fronte a Pinocchio nel film
di Matteo Garrone Pinocchio che è nato
al cinema qualche anno fa Ebbene è una
scena fondamentale per il giornalismo
Seguitemi Geppetto scolpisce un pezzo di
legno informe e crede che da quel pezzo
di legno nasca una vita nasca un bambino
e allora inizia a scolpire piano piano
togliendo scolpendo escono le clavicole
e poi le spalle e poi Viva Dio esce il
collo e poi la testa le orecchie questo
naso questo meraviglioso naso di
Pinocchio e improvvisamente scalpellando
cioè togliendo ed è questa la parola che
vi consiglio togliendo da forma e dando
forma si accorge improvvisamente che nel
petto di Pinocchio inizia a battere
qualcosa Qualcosa che ha un alito di
vita qualcosa che non è più un pezzo di
legno in forma ma è un essere umano
e quel cuore che batte gli fa paura lui
avvicina l'orecchio e sente questo cuore
e si e indietreggia e poi Allora gli
dice no allora devi parlarmi devi dirmi
se mi sei figlio e gli dice di babbo la
parola più bella mamma babbo
e Pinocchio dice babbo
e Geppetto indietro ancora perché quello
che ha creato ormai vive di vita propria
perché è conscio di avere un figlio ed
esce fuori in mezzo al cortile in mezzo
alla notte e grida mi è stato dato un
figlio e la stessa cosa succede a noi a
noi col giornalismo dove la materia
informe è quello dalla quale dobbiamo
togliere togliere la muffa togliere i su
strati togliere la polvere per far
vivere il cuore e una volta tolto è
fatto vivere tutto questo l'inchiesta
l'inchiesta giornalistica cammina con le
proprie gambe e arriva a voi che
raccogliete dalle vostre case dai vostri
divani leggendo la mattina i giornali e
quindi la paternità non biologica che è
stata mia come giornalista diventa anche
vostra diventa vostra perché vi
appartiene quella cosa lì
e quella paternità e quella maternità
è qualcosa che riguarda tutti noi se
l'informazione è davvero un bene e viva
Dio se ciascuno di voi oltre a noi può
interessarsi un essere padre e un essere
madre delle informazioni
Grazie
[Applauso]